الصوره هي ذات الصوره التي نقلت قبل قليل
عبر العربيه من الزميل هاني هنا في
بورسودان الصوره تكمل ما يحدث الان في
الجانب الاخر في ميناء جده نحن الان في
ميناء بورسودان الان استعدادات لنقل عدد
اثنين وخمسين من رعايه الدول الاجنبيه
تحديدا من البعثات الدبلوماسيه التي وصلت
الى مدينه بورسودان
بتنسيق وباشراف من قبل السفاره السعوديه
الان هذه هي قوات البحريه الملكيه
السعوديه تستعد الان
العبور نحو جلاله الملك الجبيل هذه
السفينه والقطعه البحريه التي ترى الان في
ميناء بورسودان لاجلاء 52 من ممثلي
البعثات الدبلوماسيه نتحدث عن ثمانيه من
بريطانيا وتسعه من جنوب افريقيا
وسبعه من روسيا واحد الدبلوماسيين من دوله
غانا وعن شخصين من السودان وكينيا 18
دبلوماسي وبنغلاديش اثنين وامريكا واحد
والنيجر واحد وليبيا دبلوماسي واحد وكندا
وغينيا دبلوماسي لكل دوله هذه العمليه كما
ذكرنا تاتي باشراف متواصل من قبل الجيش
السوداني وبتنسيق مشترك مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه هذه العمليه السعوديه
يشرف عليها العقيد خالد غازي بن شلاوي
حلعطاوي وهو مساعد الملحق العسكري المشرف
على عمليه الاجلاء في سفينه جلاله الملك
الجبيل هو الان يناقش مع قيادات الجيش
السوداني التي ايضا تنسخ هذه العمليه
وترتب عبر وحدات مختلفه وعبر لجان تتعلق
باستقبال الجوازات بحصر الاعداد التي وصلت
الى
بورسودان الى ميناء بورسودان التنسيق
مشترك بين السودان بين الجيش السوداني
وبين القوات المسلحه السعوديه وبين
البحريه الملكيه السعوديه التمضي هذه
الاجراءات هذا البسط السفري على متنه الان
52 من الممثلي البعثات الدبلوماسيه نسقوا
مع المملكه العربيه السعوديه بهدف اجلائهم
من السودان وصولا الى ميناء جده عدد من
الدبلوماسيين الان وصلوا قبل يومين الى
ميناء بورسودان
نتحدث الان عن اكثر من
2500 شخص تم اجلائهم خلال الساعات الماضيه
من ميناء بورت سودان هنا في شرق السودان
عبورا بالبحر الاحمر وصولا الى ميناء جده
الاعداد الان في ازدياد نسبه دبلوماسيين
ورعايا الدول التي تنسق مع المملكه
العربيه السعوديه وتنسق مع الجيش السوداني
الذي يشرف اشرافا كاملا على هذه العمليه
بالتنسيق كما ذكرنا مع الهيئات البعثات
الدبلوماسيه لاجلاء الرعايه هذه الصوره
التي تنقل الان لديها نسخه اخرى ولكن ليس
عبر البحر وانما عبر الجوف في مطار
بورسودان ايضا استمرار الرحلات الجويه
للقطع الجويه العسكريه التي تصل تباعا
بواقع ست الى سبعه الى ثمانيه رحلات في
اليوم الحديث عن اكثر من الف مسافر من
بورسودان عبر المطار الى عدد من القواعد
في المنطقه وعدد من مطارات الدول
القريبه هذه العمليه الان مستمره بعد قليل
ينتقل 52 من ممثلي البعثات الدبلوماسيه
الى جانب قوات البحريه الملكيه التي
سترافق الدبلوماسيين من ميناء بورسودان
وصولا الى المربط الذي وصلت اليه جلاله
الملكه الجبيل وبعدها مباشره بعد استكمال
الاجراءات تمضي هذه السفينه الى ميناء جده
لاست قبالها في الجانب الاخر حيث وفرت
المملكه العربيه السعوديه كافه
الاستعدادات وكافه الترتيبات الفنيه
والاداريه
الاستقبال مئات الرعايه الدبلوماسيين
الذين وصلوا من جده باشراف من قبل الجيش
السوداني وبتنسيق مشترك ومحكم بين السودان
وبين المملكه العربيه السعوديه التي تواصل
هذا الجهد المشترك في سبيل اجلاء الرعايه
الذين نسقوا ورتبوا مع سفاره المملكه
العربيه السعوديه في السودان
طيب نزار اهل من حالات صحيه حرجه تصل الى
الميناء وتحاول الخروج من السودان كذلك هل
تم يعني الاعلان عن اي حالات مشابهه لذلك
حتى الان الامور حسب الجهات المعنيه وحسب
اللجنه لجنه الاجلاء المكونه من قبل الجيش
والتي تتعامل مع من يغادرون عبر عمليه
الاجلاء سواء كان في البحر او عبر الجو لم
تسجل اي حالات لحالات مرضيه او اصابات او
او اعراض صحيه هنالك ايضا لجنه صحيه تتابع
هذا الامر وتحكم على راحه المسافرين هنالك
ايضا لجنه تعمل على حصر اعداد الذين وصلوا
الى مدينه بورسودان ويتم حصر كل الاسماء
في منطقه محدده وهي نادي هيئه الموانئ
البحريه بمدينه بورسودان اللجان المعنيه
تقول بانها تمضي وفق ثلاثه تسيطر على
الامر على الرغم من حالات الانتظار الشديد
وحالات
الوصول المستمره الى مدينه بورسودان
والنسب الكبيره من القادمين برا من
الخرطوم من مدينه مدني من مدينه المعبره
الى ميناء بورسودان الى مطار بورسودان هذه
العمليه تحتاج الى تنسيق تحتاج الى تدريب
تحتاج الى تعاون هذا الامر يبدو الان بانه
يمضي هنالك عقبات ولكن اللجان المعنيه
تقول بانها على قدر التحدي للتعامل مع كل
هذه العقبات في سبيل انجاح اكبر عمليه
اجلاء لرعايه الدول الاجنبيه من السودان
طيب يعني
خلال حديثك نزار واتخيل بانك تمكنت من
الحديث مع الاشخاص الذين يريدون الخروج من
السودان اثر الاشتباكات والمعارك الدائره
ما القصص الانسانيه التي رموها لك
يعني معظم القصص التي تروى من قبل
المواطنين او من قبل رعايا الدول الاجنبيه
هي حالات الذعر والخوف التي
لامسوها وعايشوها عندما خرجوا من العاصمه
الخرطوم وقبل ان يخرجوا الاستماع الى صوت
الرصاص
الحالات الخوف والهلع التي اصابتهم عندما
هموا بالخروج بعضهم كان يشتكي من التعرض
لعمليات سلب وهو يغادر العاصمه الخرطوم
لكن بعد ان استلم الجيش زمام الامر في هذه
العمليه ومرحله التامين والخروج بعد ان
نسقت معظم السفارات مع الاطراف في الخرطوم
وصلوا مباشره الى شرق السودان الى مدينه
بورسودان بعدها الامور كانت تمضي بسلاسه
الحديث عن حاله هدوء عن طمانينه على اوضاع
مستقره هنا في الشرق السودان خلافا لما
حدث في العاصمه الخرطوم فقط المعاناه كانت
تتعلق بكيفيه الخروج من العاصمه بامان
وهؤلاء نجحوا
بالخروج وهم الان في طريقهم لمغادره
السودان كما تتابعون عبر هذا البسط السفري
الذي ينتظر
البواخر الصغيره التي ستقلهم من ميناء
بورسودان مباشره الى الباخره الجبيل التي
ترابط في احد المراسي هنا في مدينه
بورسودان لنقلهم جميعا حتى يتمكنوا من
الوصول الى الجانب الاخر من البحر في
ميناء جده
نزار يعني
بختم معك هل من انباء وارده لديك من
الخرطوم ومجريات المعارك هناك والاشتباكات
من العاصمه السودانيه
نعم الاخبار الوارده من الخرطوم حالات
الاشتباكات المتقطعه القطع العسكريه
التابعه للجيش السوداني بدات في الوفود
والتحرك من مختلف المناطق وصولا الى
العاصمه السودانيه الخرطوم بعض المناطق
كما علمنا قبل قليل صباحا بانها بدات تعود
اليها الحياه تدريجيا في عدد من المناطق
في منطقه ام درمان في الشرق العاصمه
الخرطوم في جنوب الخرطوم عدد من المناطق
الان المواطنون يحاولون بشق الانفس ان
يستعيدوا ولو قليلا من نمط حياتهم الذي
كان قبل اندلاع هذه الاحداث قبل 13
يوما لكن حاله الخوف ايضا تسيطر
الاشتباكات المتقطعه في عدد من الامكنه هي
التي تعيق ان تعود الحياء الى مسارها
الطبيعي والكره الان في السودان يعول على
الحله السلمي يعول على رجاحه العقل يعول
على اسكات صوت البندقيه يعول على الحلول
السلميه
الصراع من اجل ان تهدا اصوات الرصاص وان
تعود الحياء الى ما كانت عليه مشير ايضا
الى استمرار حالات الخروج من العاصمه
شمالا عبر شريان الشمال نحو دنقله شرقا من
العاصمه الخرطوم الى مدينه مدني وسط
السودان في ولايه الجزيره ومنها الى شرق
السودان على معبر الجلابات الذي يفضي الى
اثيوبيا بعض الولايات المجاوره للعاصمه
السودانيه الخرطوم الحديث عن جنوب الخرطوم
الى ولايه النيل الابيض شمال الخرطوم الى
ولايه نهر النيل الجنوب الخرطوم الى ولايه
الجزيره هذه المنافذ المتاحه الان
السودانيين للتعاطي مع هذه الازمه التي
حللت بهم قبل ثلاثه عشر يوما شكرا لكن
العربيه من مدينه بورت سودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على يوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات